you may have heard about a new battle
between Congress and the Department of
Justice a group of congressional
Republicans is demanding that the Deputy
Attorney General rot Rosenstein released
a series of documents related to the
Russia investigation they say they plan
to impeach Rosenstein if he doesn't turn
over the information so far Rosenstein
has defiantly refused to do that
now before you tune this out is yet
another partisan arcane debate the kind
that washington specialises in here the
details because it's not that there's a
lot at stake here far beyond the
short-term political advantage of either
party the russia investigation as you
know has completely dominated the
business of government since the day
Trump took office it's all anyone in
Washington can talk or think about
never mind the potential Wars on the
horizon in Asia or the Middle East where
the facts our own economy and culture
are changing faster than anyone can
understand or digest in DC only the
Muller investigation matters so you may
wonder what is the Muller investigation
what is it about what exactly is Muller
investigating turns out almost nobody
knows except rod Rosenstein he knows but
he won't tell Congress last summer Rosen
Stein wrote a memo detailing the scope
of the Independent Counsel investigation
key portions of that memo remain hidden
from view Congress would like to see
them and has every right to see them our
Constitution requires our elected
representatives to supervise the
Department of Justice why is that well
so that bureaucrats with massive law
enforcement and surveillance powers
remain accountable to voters we give
them guns let them arrest us send us to
prison allow them to break into our
private email accounts tap our phones
they have a lot of power in return they
promise not to misuse that power if
there's any question about their honesty
we get to check
that's what transparency is government
bureaucrats hate transparency they'd
rather do their work in secret
secrecy is the shield that protects them
from our scrutiny and not just in this
case consider the House Intelligence
Committee investigation into Russian
collusion it was just completed it took
a year to complete the final report ran
to 253 pages yet the rest of us couldn't
really read it because key facts were
missing just how many Trump associates
did the Obama administration spy on
during
2016 campaign it would be nice to know
that sorry it's redacted is there any
actual proof that the Russian government
directed hacking of the DNC and John
Podesta's gmail account well if there is
that's been redacted - how about this
the report says that the FBI agents who
interviewed Mike Flynn didn't believe he
was lying but wait Mike Flynn pleaded
guilty to lying to those agents and his
life was destroyed as the result he just
sold his house to raise money for his
legal-defense so what's going on here
well we don't know that information was
redacted why were all these redactions
made we don't even know that we asked no
one would tell us and then there's the
FISA application to spy on Trump
campaign aide Carter page that hasn't
been released either even though we now
have ample reason to believe the
application may have been fundamentally
illegitimate based heavily on
discredited partisan hearsay the steel
dossier Jim Comey denies this of course
he's denied it repeatedly on his book
tour just the other day he noted smiling
faintly as he said it if there's no way
to check really because it's classified
the joke is on us except it's not funny
almost nobody trusts the government
anymore and that's one subject that both
sides can agree on there's only one way
to fix that
Sonlight stop hiding stop lying tell us
what's really going on
rod Rosen Stein has no intention of
doing any of that in an interview today
at the Newseum Rosen's town compared
demands for greater transparency from
Congress to a mafia shakedown watch
there were people who have been making
threats privately and publicly against
me for quite some time and I think they
should understand by now the Department
of Justice is not going to be extorted
we're going to do what's required by the
rule of law and any kind of threats that
anybody makes are not going to affect
the way we do our job little victim
extorted how about accountable nobody
elected rod Rosen Stein to anything or
any of these people they work for us
supposedly on our behalf when they won't
explain what they're doing or why
they're doing it it is a sure sign
always and everywhere that they have
begun to work against us that's what it
means
Jodi Jenna is a former US Attorney for
the District of Columbia he joins us now
I
it's hard to believe that just happened
that rod Rosenstein about whom I was in
vivillon until today would get out there
and attack the Congress which has
constitutional oversight over his
department as mafia members in effect
for asking for what the Constitution
demands they have which is oversight the
Deputy Attorney General today
disqualified himself from continued
service in the Department of Justice
Jeff Sessions now has an absolute
responsibility to call him into his
office berate him for saying that
constitutional oversight is extortion
that statement by a constitutional
officer like rod Rosenstein is
disgraceful it's an embarrassment to the
department but it is of a pattern of
what mr. Rosen Stein has done there
since he arrived he is a careerist he
believes that the department can do no
wrong and that he is going to resist
calls for more information when you
realize that he appointed a special
counsel robert muller
someone he's very close to and who was
very close to James Comey to investigate
no crime and put this country through 15
going on 16 months of interruption of a
new president that tells you something
about Ruud rod Rosenstein he is
resisting all of this because he created
the original sin an investigation of no
crime I'm just confused though I mean
rod Rosen Stein has a gun he's the power
to arrest you or me lying to him as a
felony here's a lot of power what does
he think that power comes from if not
from the Congress and the voters who
elected those members of Congress when
you are as arrogant and as deep in the
belief that you have been given a duty
to do whatever you think is right for
the country and when you hate the
President of the United States as I am
now convinced mr. Rosen Stein does then
you believe you can do anything and when
the Attorney General's because God made
you all-powerful or something do they
not understand where the power comes
from voters that's the only place that
comes from he does not understand it
because as a careerist and someone who
has never left government for a minute
to speak of of any note government is
all he knows and for him the most
important thing is the next job and I
can assure you the one thing he doesn't
want to happen is to be held in contempt
or to be impeached because he believes
himself to be something very very
special and unaccountable bureaucrat
so the DOJ and there are some great
people who work there yes I know our
time with him yes I spoke to one of them
today and said why not why doesn't the
Congress why doesn't the public have a
right to know what this is about
and this person said well it's an
ongoing investigation and I guess my
argument would be the public's need to
know what this is about supersedes that
but tell me your view the answer is it's
not an ongoing investigation it's there
is no crime they've already conceded
that the president is not a target
they're asking those 49 questions that
they want to ask the president and maybe
even with a grand jury subpoena because
they want to impeach the president this
has nothing to do with a criminal
investigation Donald Trump has done
nothing wrong
he's conspired with no one the reason
they are threatening a subpoena well go
ahead please issue the subpoena because
it will be an unconstitutional subpoena
and illegal subpoena because there is no
authority under federal law to issue a
subpoena to a President of the United
States to get testimony from him so it
can be used in an impeachment proceeding
that use of the grand jury is illegal
absolutely illegal this may be a debate
that continues I have the feeling Joe to
Genoa thank you for that perspective
thanks Gina